let's bring in the europe minister james
cleverly mr cleverley thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
humanitarian corridors uh refugees being
bombed as they try to flee how can we
help
well we
we see these images and of course
everybody wants to help in whatever way
they can and we've seen a huge
generosity of the british people in
collecting
things like nappies and and food and
medical supplies which are being shipped
out to poland and the ukrainian border
the government announced of course our
own humanitarian aid package 100 million
in economic support over uh
120 million in direct humanitarian
support and we have of course also
announced the fact that we will be
opening uh two schemes by which
ukrainians can come to the uk the family
reconciliation scheme
and also a broader humanitarian scheme
because we want to come to that we want
to also we will come to ukrainians in
that way as well yeah under what
circumstances would we consider
given that we've seen babies in arms
being murdered and their mothers as well
as they try to flee under what
circumstances would we consider a no-fly
zone so the russians can't do that well
this has been discussed at length and
both the secretary general of nato the
prime minister and others have said that
we've got to understand what a no-fly
zone means it would mean that not only
would there be a russian aircraft
prevented from fly but also ukrainian
aircraft from uh prevented from flying
and in order to bring a no-fly zone
in it would need to be enforced and that
would almost inevitably mean that we
would be engaged directly
with russian aircraft and
dragged into this conflict directly
which we've said is not appropriate for
uh for nato
but we are uh continuing to provide
defensive military equipment support to
the ukrainian armed forces
we've seen that be incredibly effective
um those uh end laws those those
anti-tank missiles that we've provided
and the training that we've given over
the years have proven to be really
really effective but
the the secretary general of nato and
others have made it clear that we we
must not uh be engaged directly in this
conflict okay if um refugees do manage
to get as far as calais why aren't we
making it easier for them to get into
the uk
well we
we are
we have made it absolutely clear that we
will be
supportive of refugees at the moment of
course
the vast vast majority of refugees are
in the country's
neighboring
ukraine and we are providing
humanitarian support to those refugees
via those host nation countries because
that's where that's where the problem is
at the moment most of these people of
course want to get back to their own
homes
as quickly as possible we have made it
clear that of course we will be generous
and open-hearted as you would expect to
ukrainians speaking to come here to the
uk okay
okay let me play this to you then given
what you've just said
the french people let me through they
let me through but then you come to the
uk border in calais
and and they said i'm sorry you can't
get on a ferry uh we'll escort you back
up to the office
so we're not making it easy at all are
we
well i don't know the details of that
particular circumstance but the um but
the the uk we have made it absolutely
clear we want to support uh ukrainians
who are seeking refuge uh both those who
have family connections here in the uk
uh and indeed those who don't um and
yeah over the last 10 days or so we've
seen huge numbers of people
leaving ukraine fleeing from the
conflict we will as i say support them
in the places where they currently are
which is typically
in the countries uh bordering ukraine
but we will of course also welcome
ukrainians uh here to to the uk
we've only got a limited amount of time
mr cleverly 13 and a half thousand
people have applied to uh
come to the uk visa applications so far
one can only imagine how difficult it is
to do that in a war zone they have we've
allowed 50 to be granted that's not
acceptable
well you've got to remember that this
situation has occurred only over the
last couple of days one and a half
million people have gone into ireland
this situation has only occurred in the
last couple of days of course the vast
majority of people have just crossed the
border into
the neighboring countries and of course
what we are saying is we are supporting
them there we have allocated hundreds of
millions of pounds worth of humanitarian
and economic support we are also going
to make sure that we host ukrainians
here in the uk whether uh temporarily
until we want to go back to the uk
we've got to we have got to make we have
got to make sure we've got to make sure
that we um we have uh the uh you know
processes in place to do that and those
processes these people literally are
fleeing for their life if you're going
to ask questions you've got to let me
answer you keep saying you're sure i'm
so sad we only have a limited amount of
time and you're going off at a tangent
i'm bringing you back
this is what my viewers want to know
this morning minister if i may
13 and a half thousand people have asked
to come to the uk 50 have been told that
they can we just heard from a brit there
who's brought his family he's in calais
he can't get across the water he was
welcomed all the way he wants to come
home and we won't let him
well as i say i don't have details of
that if you pass me the details of that
individual case i'll make sure that we
that we look at that but we have
processes in place whereby people with
family here in the uk and indeed those
without family in the uk can come to the
uk you see so far only small numbers
have come thus far and i would remind
you that the process has only just
started and the vast majority of people
are physically still in the country's
neighboring uk so neighboring ukraine
that is where we are providing the
support initially because that's where
the problem currently is we want to help
these people whether they be
in uh in bulgaria slovakia poland where
a large number of people are but also we
want to help them when they come to the
uk and we have okay two routes family
reconciliation route and a route for
people that don't have family both
voters
50 people out of 13 and a half thousand
have been allowed in so far that those
are well that number let me talk to you
if i may because we only have a limited
amount of time as i said the
conversation minister if i may thank you
minister minister if you're gonna ask me
a question let me answer it i've asked
you several times and we've gone around
the houses on that one the conversation
between the two leaders both our leader
and uh the leader of ukraine um we have
agreed that we'll send further defensive
equipment what does that actually
involve will it include fighter jets
no we've we've already said we're not
going to engage in uh no-fly zone we
have seen the equipment that has been
incredibly effective uh those
n laws those anti-tank missile systems
and other equipment which would probably
best not uh discussed uh on the on the
television but the point is that we have
continued to do what we have done over
years which is support ukrainians in
their defense um the the feedback that
we have from them about that has been
uh has been really heartening they value
that equipment that we have supplied
them it's made a it's made a real
difference and we'll continue as part of
the prime minister's six-point plan we
will continue
to help the ukrainians defend themselves
against this illegal completely
unjustified attack
the economic crime bill in parliament uh
today labour's tabled an amendment to
shorten the enforcement to 28 days i
believe presently it's looking like
something like six months is that
something that the government will
consider
well obviously we are working across
party to make sure this is as effective
as possible
i have to say in my conversations with
the labour front bench
they have been incredibly pragmatic in
their desire to make sure this is
effective as possible obviously we'll
see what happens with regard to the
amendments i'm sure there'll be others
tabled as well but the ultimate goal
is to make sure that the sanctions that
we've already put in place which are
incredibly effective and have had real
impact on russian oligarchs and indeed
the russian
economy are made even stronger still and
we welcome cross-party support in that
the prime minister said a hundred 275
individuals have been sanctioned a
hundred individuals last week alone
looking at a fact-checker
our figures are suggesting that is 15
which of those figures is correct well
your figures are wrong
okay why is the prime minister's figures
um correct 100 individuals are you sure
well we have we've uh we've targeted
sorry that's what he said in parliament
didn't he
well as i said the the figures you put
forward i don't recognize those figures
at all we've had a very wide ranging
number um
over 200 individuals and entities over
250 billion
pounds worth of uh
russian economic activity curtailed
over three million russian companies now
longer able to raise finance on the
london market so the fact that vladimir
putin singled us out for criticism is a
badge of honor and i think that we will
see that strengthen even further still
okay unfortunately i do have to go i
told your studio that i have to be clear
for another interview i have at 7 20. so
i'm afraid i'm going to have to go now
i'm sure thank you
thank you